I'm gonna open a glass of roses please
please you've created a way to kind of
Be An American Royal in your own way
here's why I think you are a royal you
Traverse the country with a Cavalry you
have your own meat like this is the way
Royals used to do it do you own your own
Chariot okay I'm Prince Philip you are
received when you go to a place you're
received by adoring masses I am Prince
Philip and you do this all while
enjoying the spoils of a glass of wine I
love your brakes cocktail or a feast
this is you can drink whatever I want I
gotta put on fancy clothes at the end of
the night if you describe the life of a
royal to someone who had been on the
planet a few minutes and you described
your life they would go oh he's a royal
now it's because America and Americans
have a fifth grade reading level